and as soon as i opened the closet there
was a little meth head
pointing the cold 45 right at me and
fired it and if it hit him in the chest
boom he said he got knocked over
[ __ ] skedaddled out the window and
just ran into the woods
this [ __ ] disappeared and this guy
survived it
and i'm just like he hit a bulletproof
vest yeah
he he had all this tactical gear and
everything second amendment right
holy [ __ ] i said in five four
three two one what's up everybody
welcome to another episode of the genius
brain podcast
we have another episode with of course
ed
park also known ed park
here in the house if this is your first
time listening to the podcast this is a
podcast about
literally anything and everything we're
just here to kind of keep you company
about your day
i'm a former stripper and also a belly
dancer if you guys don't know
if you're only watching this on video
you clearly know i'm lying but
if i was we were just talking uh uh i
was talking to ed about
uh i sent him this link or i might not
send in the link
but it's there's just one um korean
series
where it's it's a thriller and the
thriller series
is about uh this family who is going
through hard times
and they get accepted into this church
right okay so in korea
there are these extreme forms of
christianity that are cultish
extreme cultures you'll see these people
out on the streets trying to recruit
people all the time
and that's what this whole thriller
series is about
so this family um you see them driving
like in the dark and in the rain and
basically not to spoil it they they get
to the point where they go
to the area with this it's called uh
who's here one or something like that or
something i can't remember the exact
name right now i watched it a while ago
it's called kuz hello which is the area
or the church area or the church camp
right
and so they meet these people
and you could tell that they're they're
very friendly very nice
and uh but the head leader he kind of
looks like cultish right he's a korean
guy with blonde hair
okay right wearing a white suit yeah you
know and he's saying that he's like the
messiah like he's like the chosen one
but these people are basically going to
this and they're like oh these people
are really nice like they're giving us a
place to live
like your father doesn't have any work
they're they're giving us food clothes
and a place to live for free yeah and
basically this is like the start of them
going into this church and
it was so creepy watching this stuff
because it reminded me a lot
of the extreme religious heads that were
in the korean church
like everything that you did if it
wasn't for god is because
satan is controlling you and they kept
saying this throughout the whole [ __ ]
film
like everything is the dabber and they
would try to there's like parts where
they start speaking in tongue
oh no dude ed that's traumatic for me
dude you should watch if you watch this
part of my life man the best part of my
life
and there's parts to where they're
trying to like take the devil out of the
body so they're saying
you know this means like i i believe in
god or i believe in his word like
that and they're striking people's backs
like yeah like literally beating this
[ __ ] up wigglesworth [ __ ] yeah
yo you gotta i forgot about that [ __ ]
smith wigglesworth
google it you gotta tell that story it's
just still
i mean like um because i grew up
not grew up but i went down a path where
i was missionary for a few years
yeah and i did a lot of missionary
training and i dug into the word
very deeply and into the doctrine and
the people you're studying
it with they got some stories they have
weird stories
and you also learn through history about
this guy
named smith wigglesworth that was his
real name he was just like
last century preacher and early 1900s
preacher
who would go around performing
quote-unquote miracles
like apparently punching a dude in the
stomach and making his
tumor come out his back or his ass
so another story about like and then
they'll tell these stories like yeah
dude he was he was a legend man he was a
miracle worker
like sucking somebody in the stomach and
saying a tumor flew out his back
are you [ __ ] kidding me dude and then
they said a couple
brought a dead infant to smith
wigglesworth
and they were like please pray for our
child we're going to bury him
so the story goes that he takes the baby
drops it in front of him
punts the baby kicks it and it [ __ ]
flies and hits the wall
hits the ground and starts crying so
it's alive
it's a miracle that's the story and
everyone that
these like religious circles i was in
was just like isn't that amazing
i was like what the [ __ ] did you just
say to me right now smith
wigglesworth that's his name when this
fool told me this [ __ ] we had we
actually stopped and
hold on we gotta look this up you can
google
smith wigglesworth and this man exists
like we don't know about the stories
being real right but this is a real
[ __ ] person
there are all these people like i mean
when we're talking about like the
cultish side of it like we look at
the world we live in today like
not half but the big chunk of country
believes in some conspiracy in one way
or another like we see it all around us
today especially with
quote election fraud uh q anon
and all that [ __ ] let me tell you when i
was in
chill or let me not say the name of the
town when i was back home
in the middle of nowhere let's say the
quote real america
right they believe that stuff the q and
stuff
the planes [ __ ] poisoning us and like
micro trips microchips inside vaccines
and
they all believe that stuff and they
think i'm an idiot for listening
to new york times you know what the
weirdest thing too it's like it's these
people
who are literally the the dumps of
america right and they're like i got
the government's out here trying to get
my secrets
of what how to skim a possum in like
[ __ ] ten seconds
what do we need to know from them what
are you talking about care about you the
nsa
might be listening in but what are what
about you is so
like important yo let me tell you this
[ __ ] like when i was working at my
parents store
you know when i was younger like uh
i wouldn't i wouldn't really talk back a
lot right because i was kind of timid
and scared but when you get older
like you're in the store like this is
your store yeah right and i started
getting really comfortable with it
and there'd be some [ __ ] hilarious
people that would walk in let me tell
you this is one person i remember what i
said to this person
and it was like a moment where i'm like
i'm so sick of this [ __ ]
this lady she was trying to pay for her
stuff right first of all
it's it's a beauty supply store yeah
there's nothing of necessary goods here
and she's like
she's gonna pay for her hair piece and
she's like she whips out her ebt card
right and i'm looking i was like ma'am
you can't pay for hair stuff with your
ebt you can't even pay for hot food
yeah she's like why not and i'm like
that's not how ebts work this is not a
necessity you can't pay for hot food
with this
why the [ __ ] do you think that you could
pay for your [ __ ] you know 21 inch
weave or whatever you know like what the
[ __ ] are you thinking right now right
and i'm like
yo you can't pay with an ebt yeah right
and she's
pissed at me like because i won't take
her ebt
literally food for food
right and i'm like yo this lady is
tripping right now right at the most
i'll let you buy diapers with it
you know she's like fine whatever right
and then she's like
she puts i give her the machine she puts
in her debit card right
yeah and she stops and right before
she's about to press in her number for
her debit card she thought she looks at
me she goes
try to look at my number i'm like [ __ ]
you just try to patient with your ebt
how much money is inside your [ __ ]
bank account right now
right and she goes oh you think you're
so funny i was like
am i trying to steal you you just try to
pay for your [ __ ] with an ebt card what
what if i wanted to take your identity i
kill myself dude
like are you kidding me right now the
[ __ ] audacity dude these yeah i mean
you know what it is it's entitlement
even though these people
are broke or whatever they have this
really weird sense of entitlement so
like this guy
came in he wanted to buy a foster's you
know fosters are those big fat
cans and it's 349 plus tax
this [ __ ] brings 355
in nickels and like there's tax
dude and like look i'll take it if i can
look it's
money money's money right yeah but it's
not enough
you know and it's like what look i work
hard and i come here all my life to pay
for this and i'm just like
you come here all your life and you like
i'm supposed to take your nickels
so that you have that entitlement yeah
you still don't have enough
and there's tax if i don't charge you
for the tax i'm in trouble
yeah the funny dude every everybody
knows this right
like if you worked at any joint in the
hood
people never understand what the [ __ ]
tax i'm telling you straight up
every [ __ ] time man like people
didn't understand the [ __ ] that i
i would have to go through because
number one people think that we were
rich yeah because we have this business
oh my god and i'm like
i'm poorer than you i don't think you
understand this
i'm either as poor or even more poor
than you
we struggled together yeah i was like
you don't get it just because i work
here
and we have this business doesn't mean i
make more than you we're barely getting
[ __ ] by
right and so like they would like do
[ __ ] my mom would always say this [ __ ]
she goes
they would get like scrunchies right and
it would be the same [ __ ]
my mom would be like three for a dollar
it goes what
let me tell you this [ __ ] this is this
is so fresh she goes four for a dollar
right and so we will ring them up and it
would come out to 108
with tax yeah right and she goes
without fail at least one person y'all a
bunch of [ __ ] crooks
you said it was a dollar i'm like my
mom's like texting not
mine yeah i had to say this text is not
mine it's a government tax is not mine
right and they're like then why'd you
say it was a dog i'm like yo [ __ ]
where [ __ ] else do you go anywhere
else where you don't get charged for tax
why are you [ __ ] sweating this
even people try to argue with me that
gatorade shouldn't be charged taxed
like dude are you kidding there's
chemicals in this [ __ ]
yeah these all all drinks outside of
water taxed
yeah especially in washington state
sugar attacks yeah people are so mad at
me yeah they're mad at us dog one of the
funniest things too i remember i told
this [ __ ] in class in high school people
were cracking up because they were i was
like this is just some real [ __ ] that i
was dealing with they thought i was
doing like a stand-up [ __ ] and i'm like
no this is just my life
stop [ __ ] laughing like the same [ __ ]
too right the same lady
who gives a [ __ ] for the for the dollar
for the tax [ __ ] right
this is like you always hear this like
hood [ __ ] and like uh
she goes i was like she goes well how
much can i how much can i get for just
one then
right i'm like it's four for a dollar so
you get one for 25 cents she goes oh so
that's how you get us
and i'm like is that a comeback i'm like
what i was like yes
it's 25 cents each that that's how the
math works she goes no i see you
[Laughter]
you thought you could slip by me huh i'm
sitting here just
am i missing something it's the same
price
it's 25 cents four for a dollar 25 cents
one each
yeah i see you she's waiting for you to
be like all right you figured out the
second
you gained me
on this now just having to deal with
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] and it's so
funny too because
you know like i said this is like the
one for me anyways it's like one percent
of customers are like this right so 99
like you could see the other people
behind are just rolling their eyes like
[ __ ] get the
hurry the [ __ ] up like quit giving these
people [ __ ]
i mean like so like we would always have
a customer that had to step in and be
like
yo chill yeah you know yo
you're gonna buy this [ __ ] or not you
know because you're giving a [ __ ] do you
have debit fees
yeah we have data fees oh my god and how
much complaining was there for that [ __ ]
dude
we always told him too it's like look
anything under yeah we
pay it up front yeah you know with the
credit card companies
they charge us yeah right so we lose
every time
you give us a debit card yeah that's why
all these stores have
you know fees yeah and um they just call
me a thief they call me whatever
and there was same thing one point where
there's this line
and this guy's like i'm calling the
better business bureau you can't do this
charge me for debit fee and there's a
line going out
and even the people in line was like guy
like
we all have debit fees are you from this
state yeah he wasn't he was from oregon
yeah of course they're not taxed yeah
they're not taxed that's why
they don't know that [ __ ] but you so you
come to our state and complain about our
taxes what are you doing here
why do you think we go to oregon to buy
cars yeah
because you guys don't have a [ __ ]
tax that's hilarious dude
but um yeah i think uh just
seeing the small world out there like
for those people that
is their world that is their territory
that isn't
so like the i guess that
taxation part of it means a lot to them
more
because at the same time you look at our
world today in poverty they don't have
much
but then they're getting taxed as [ __ ]
too right yeah
like people at our store they live
in a whole lot of poverty in drugs
a lot of meth addicts like um
so this employee i'm gonna
his name's not jim i'm just gonna call
him jim yeah just for the story
yeah so he's a good kid i don't actually
know how old he is
he looks like a teen but he's got a full
mustache
he drives a lot more to work to my store
every day
get the [ __ ] out of here no he suit up
his lawnmower his riding alarm
he comes to my store he does not he
drives a [ __ ]
like hank hill yeah yeah like hank hill
a [ __ ] lawnmower and he comes to my
store every day
i did not hear this part this is [ __ ]
nuts and so
the way this guy
trash [ __ ] is this dude no parole this
guy shows up and
first day of work i'm like all right so
let's work on stalking right
you put [ __ ] on the shelves and so
this podcast is brought to you by cbd
farmhouse my
friends if you haven't tried cbd
products you should give it a go because
for me
it has helped me so much with my anxiety
and when i
train it helps me with my soreness
specifically one of the products that i
really really enjoy right now is the
freezing
roll-on this one specifically my god
anytime i'm sore or if i have joint pain
because i kick box a lot like recently i
hit the bag really weird that i hurt my
wrist
i put this on and then like i'd say like
a minute or two
i could move it again and it felt really
great um
i don't know what i do without these
products and trust me not
all cbd places are made the same this
place specifically
does a lot of their stuff or if anything
else all their stuff in in-house
so the quality control of their products
is insane
and i need consistency when i purchase
stuff like this because i don't want to
get a product that's good one day
the next order it's bad you will never
have those issues with this company i
love them if you guys want to try cbd
farmhouse all you have to do is go to
cbdfarmhouse.com
and at checkout enter brain and you'll
get 15
off any order that has non-sale items
that's 15
off all you have to do once again is go
to cbdfarmhouse.com
and enter codebrain to get 15 off today
i'm showing him the coke's you know
bottle so here i put the coke in
diet coke here cherry coke here and
fanta here and whatever coke products
and i leave them to it i go to the
register i come back
like 10 15 minutes it's a [ __ ]
rainbow in there
everything's huckled as [ __ ] it's just
mixed i'm like yo
hey man you put like coke zero and like
coke together what are you doing and he
goes oh i'm sorry
i'm color blind no what
you know it says diet it says zero it
says
fanta grape orange
just by color he's just put it all there
bless his soul dude that's his soul he's
trying he's trying his best
and like okay so moving on to stalking
beer
this guy i don't know why but takes
out the beers out of six packs throws
away our six-pack cases
and puts all these individual single
beer cans in cases
oh my god like dog so
he's learning he's learning i find it so
funny that i just pictured this part
where you're like
they're all the colors he goes i'm color
blind and then you go
but the words are there i can't read
it's like oh no he's not i he didn't
finish school i don't know if he went to
school
at all even i don't know i know he
didn't finish
but he was a good kid and he showed up
yeah he's a good person
this is his world that's all he knew
yeah you know
and now this store is where he's getting
employed because you know what he was
doing before that
what did we squat doing nothing hanging
out with this
militia shooting his gun and his rifle
hunting squirrels and deer and elk
oh my god this is like it's like
hillbilly stuff bill billy stuff he
has nothing to do but that and then we
gave him a job and if i gave him five
dollars more than
like what he should get paid he'd wha
whoa whoa i don't i don't deserve this
oh what a sweet guy he's a really good
kid
so one day he actually shows up late
and i don't i'm not gonna call him i'm
not gonna blow him this phone like he's
yeah when he shows up though
he's [ __ ] pale and sweaty and his
eyes are sunken in
right and he goes hi uh sorry i was late
uh i got shot
what yeah yeah i i got shot
right right here on my chest hey wait
wait
what the [ __ ] are you talking about what
are you doing here go to hospital
he said his one of his militia members
died okay uh god rest his soul
and in the midst of that some squatters
like some meth heads took over his home
and so
he and his friend and his militia
got their [ __ ] together we got this yeah
jail
no as he's telling this i was like yeah
yeah yeah stop right there
why didn't you call the cops he's like
we're a militia
[Laughter]
what we got well you're looking at the
sheriff right here
you gotta understand like their rights
their second amendment
amendment rights is everything is
everything why call the cops i have the
second amendment
yeah i got my rifle so
the militia his militia they set up a
permanent we set up this house telling
it
so that permit around his house and we
all came and went in and
i had the duty of going through his
bedroom
and he goes i know that he has a cold 45
on his bed rest and it wasn't there
so i had my gun ready and i checked the
room
and as soon as i opened the closet there
was a little meth head
pointing the cold 45 right at me and he
fired it
and if it hit him in the chest boom he
said he got knocked over
[ __ ] skedaddled out the window and
just ran into the woods
[ __ ] disappeared and this guy
survived it
and i'm just like get a bulletproof vest
yeah
he he had all this tactical gear and
everything second amendment right
holy [ __ ] i said dude why are you show
up to work
what are you doing here go to the
hospital man
and he's like no he showed me he opened
up his bruise right here
and he showed me his best his is like it
was a steel plate vest
straight up big ass indent with like
[ __ ] specs
like shattered shattered [ __ ] kid got
shot and showed up to work
point blank point blank and showed up to
work
wow you know what i'm saying and he's
like hot hospital why i was like do you
have
obamacare or something i don't know man
you got shot i think he has like a
bruised lung
he kept working he was like nah like i'm
gonna go stock the beer and no mop the
floor
and he's finished right he's sweaty he's
pale
i'm like i don't know what you're gonna
do drink some water go to the hospital
do something he's like i'm all right i'm
all right
[Laughter]
these people are crazy man look man
they're good people
what a good kid though like he still
came to work
yeah i'm sorry i'm so sorry for being
late please don't fire me what happened
i got shot point blank my meth hat
excuse me dude go to the [ __ ]
hospital
yeah like like i'm not gonna like that's
one of those things
i can't take away anything from their
character and their intention
and everything that they're trying to do
their best like this kid told me he's
like
you know i've never seen a guy person in
my life until i came to this store
i'm like my store in the middle now is
where you get exposed to the world dude
i feel like i'm in prison
this world exposed you to gabe oh [ __ ] a
gas station
yeah a gas station he looks at you he
goes how long have you been a [ __ ]
i was like we don't say that and i am
not
gay yeah could have fooled me like i've
never
i've never seen like real like like gays
ever just with that guy he went like
this with the the wrist he said i've
never met a
you know guy that's crazy
yeah and so even when i had to have him
like help move
a freezer from my store to my mom's
house in her garage
when he got to my mom's neighborhood
which is a 20-minute drive
he's like what is this place i i've
never
seen this place before like dude you
live 20 minutes away
i guess he doesn't get farthest longer
my lawnmower can only go about 18
miles so seriously it's kind of hard
getting around
it's it's like that that that's his
whole world just
like a five mile radius how [ __ ] nuts
is that dude
can you believe can you imagine that him
driving like 20 miles to work
it's like him going to like uzbekistan
you know
it's like what is what are those things
on your face
it's like they're called glasses they
fix my vision
[Laughter]
what do you mean
yeah he's straight up as a flip phone
and everybody oh
my god he doesn't need [ __ ] abs for
anything he just needs to call his mom
or
her i want to meet this dude just so i
could give him a regular stuff and
record his reaction
yeah i mean this is an iphone 3.
you know that's like my god the scrum
where's the buttons
oh man i'm pretty sure he doesn't have
netflix
or wi-fi like honestly he's just out
there
one with nature so what what happened to
him at the store did you guys still keep
him on or did he
he actually
one day um he was doing some work and he
had brought his backpack to work
right and
my mom had a weird intuition just a
weird one
and out of curiosity she checked his bag
and there was a carton of camels oh
you know and a carton of cigarettes
ain't cheap yeah it's really really
expensive
you know and my mom too was just like so
disappointed i'm disappointed
disappointed
but look every single employee we've
ever had has stolen from us and this was
a good kid
yeah and he was just one of the bunch
again right
and um so my mom let him work
like that all day and then
um at the end of the day she called him
out oh what did he say
come on and then he got bright red
apparently and
no this is my friend's cigarettes like
he told me to hold him like she was like
why would a cigarette smoker tell you to
hold his cigarettes when he wants his
cigarettes 24 7.
yeah you know yeah and it was just
excuse excuse he couldn't
he couldn't come up with a good one
let's say
and my mom couldn't trust him anymore oh
you know
what it's it was sad it ruined him it
was so he got he
yeah his mom would come by every now and
then yeah
only misses all right i'll cut that but
his name is not
i'll believe i'll i'll believe it yeah
yeah jim really
misses this place you guys were like a
family to him and whatever it was like
i know he was like well he steals from
me too so he must've really liked you
he's actually stolen from me quite a few
times but
and then a few months ago my mom called
me
she was really worried she was like the
detectives like police came
they're looking for him and they won't
tell me what he did but they're looking
for him and she just feels terrible
you know oh my god it's like those
little things like
to hit this guy this gas station
is the entire world
that's crazy and a little thing like
that
flipped his world upside down yeah you
know what i'm saying and now he's out
wanted did something there's something
there's something we know oh my god dude
that's so nuts man that's what i'm
saying too like
when i sometimes like hear these stories
i always it's good perspective for
people because like we're so quick to
judge human beings right but we look at
somebody like that
how can they live and squalor like this
blah blah blah like they're
you know we i even said like trailer
park or whatever these are like jokes
that we make but they're still human
beings
you know and it's crazy how small his
world is we're just like something 10
minutes away
working at a gas station actually gave
meaning to his life yeah
you know oh yeah it's like this is a
whole new world the game it opened him
up as a [ __ ] human being
imagine if he just actually went into
the city of seattle he had been like am
i
in the future like holy [ __ ] and he
learned a lot through me
like just telling him on a weekly basis
this [ __ ] said this [ __ ] to me
this guy's called me a goo this guy
called me a [ __ ] this guy did
and he would see how people would attack
me you know
and he didn't know what to do because
you know they don't know what to do
yeah and it would just be like you know
calm down let's all be okay and then i
have that time being like if you were
here by yourself
you think they treat you the same way or
do you think it's cause i'm here
you know and at least he wouldn't say
nothing but at least he gave it a
thought
yeah you know for these guys who don't
understand
like racism at least you know he's he's
in his young 20s i'm assuming
i really don't know his age but
everybody learned about mlk and that's
as much as he knows
that the world is not racist but when
i'm i'm showing him
actually you know you guys are yeah
you know that's so crazy i just i i'm
sorry this this image of this colorblind
hillbilly riding around your area in a
souped-up lawnmower
is as [ __ ] ridiculous as they are
with all these weapons
everything but with the kind of soul and
he just makes one mistake
he was a good kid yeah great kid to be
honest like
hard worker willing to learn uh
knows he doesn't know nothing but
don't matter to him he doesn't he
doesn't have a cat i really wonder what
he did
i hope he didn't kill somebody i hope
too but we're talking about
militia second amendment rights yeah gun
collection
yeah i hope i hope he's okay dude i hope
too that's why my mom called me
yeah is that that's as much as she knows
and she just felt like
you know i hope he's okay yeah that's
about it you know yeah
my my parents used to try to hire people
too and i think like after the second
employee stole like we can't do this
like this is it's it's more stressed to
have somebody else on than for us not to
because it's hard to trust people and it
was even for us to actually one of our
relatives that were working for still
from us
so it's like that was their last straw
yeah like dude even her own [ __ ]
family is like taking skimming off the
top because my mom she's like super
like very particular about counting
money yeah right and we found out that
uh one of our relatives
uh from my dad's side who was working at
the store with us who i
thought they were super sweet and great
um
i told my mom about this uh where i
remembered i just came into the house
and i see my mom screaming at the top of
her lungs
at my at a relative and she's sitting
there with just in tears just holding
her
and my mom is cooking at the time and
she's chopping up a fish head and she's
like
crack and she just chops like with a
cleaver and i'm
frightened because i've seen my mom
angry not angry like this
you know like i think she's gonna kill
her yeah
you know and she just has to sit there
and i remember
her husband came in right because my mom
finally confronted her about it
because my mom my mom wanted to gather
enough evidence first right and then she
finally cut
like the amount of money that she still
was skimming off the top after like six
or seven months was like in the
thousands
right because we don't make that much
money so my mom's like what the [ __ ] are
we losing
where's this money going and she found
out that she was skimming a little cash
every time she was closing out the
register
and so you know she she came in and i
remember he came in through the door
and she goes the chugging saw
right and then he's like he already
knows yeah right and then he's like
he's like trying to calm her down and my
mom gets the cleaver and just goes
whack like right into the [ __ ]
butcher block and he's like oh [ __ ] i'm
like dude
my mom's gonna kill you dude like my mom
might actually murder you
you know because family is very
important to us and so like after that i
never saw them again but i heard they
moved to like wisconsin or some [ __ ]
like that
you know how it is in business like this
podcast is brought to you by
md acne my friends if you've had
problems with your skin your whole life
that's probably because you're not using
the right products
or if you're not using the products on
your face what the hell are you doing
and i know exactly how you feel because
it's hard it's hard to figure out what
you need for your skin if it's right for
your skin and sometimes when you try out
products they don't work it's stressful
as hell
well md acne has your back and i've been
using it for quite a while and let me
tell you something your boy skin popping
md acne's app eliminates these problems
by analyzing our skin
and delivering effective customized acne
treatment products with unlimited
dermatology support with free
fine tuning and product formulation so
you're not stuck with something that
doesn't work
it's pretty simple all you have to do is
download the md acne app it's going to
analyze your skin in a matter of seconds
and deliver a complete
kit of customized acne medication
cleanser and moisturizer that's tailored
to what your skin needs
also the first month's supply is for
free and all you have to do is pay for
shipping so just go to
mdaacne.com brain to download the md
acne app
analyze your skin and get your first
month's supply for free
and you just pay for shipping once again
to get that clear
skin and a month free supply go to md
acne.com
brain and just pay for free shipping my
friend that's a personal
thing like you stealing personally from
me right yeah
you feel that right when someone steals
them even a candy bar you know how
[ __ ] nice my mom is yeah
before they left my mom gave them the
money that they stole oh wow
so they could start a new life she goes
she was like i never
want to hear from you again but because
this was worth like damaging our
relationship
take this money and start your own life
and i remember when she gave it to them
they were
bawling yeah like crying yeah and she
goes take it
no we can't take it and she just shoved
it at them she goes take it and leave
and she gave them like [ __ ] like five
or six grand and i was like
she's like if it's worth it take it and
then i haven't seen them since
that's a that's a great life lesson i
know
like uh one of grace um i mean
more than you deserve mercy all that
[ __ ] that's the christian side of yours
yeah that's the christian side
you don't deserve this [ __ ] here you go
you don't deserve it but take it you
know since
you needed it so much but i heard they
started their own life over there and
they they took that money and it helped
them out so
yeah you know my mom still did what she
thought was necessary
you know but she but my mom also can't
see look at that type of behavior and
and be okay with this
so she's just like i never want to hear
from you again though
because it'll just make her mad but she
doesn't want to see them starve or
struggle
so it's like [ __ ] man this and that's
not even her blood relative that's from
my dad's side yeah
yeah you know isn't that crazy yeah i
mean the
the stealing thing i caught a guy
stealing a case of beer
let me just say uh i ended up in court
um having to testify for self-defense
so um
this is exactly how i told the jury and
the juror
the jury and the the judge the
prosecutor
the defense like i'm in court telling
the story
um minding my own business
you know i know a guy came in right ding
dong i hear it
but um doing whatever i got to do and i
hear ding dong again
but i never and i look up and nobody
came in and i never checked anyone out
so i checked the security camera this
guy is carrying off a case of our most
expensive beer
you know and i and as i
watch him walking out he drops it i hear
he just [ __ ] slips out of his hand
and he breaks the case of beer anyway he
picks it up and i watch him in the
in the video security camera and he
puts it in his car i'm like all right
all right that's it
and i ran out there and i confronted
this guy
in the car i held his door open and i
said where you going
and i see the beer in the seat i was
like that's mine that's
my beer and he looks at me and he
doesn't say anything though right he's
just silent it's wide-eyed
i'm like where are you going with that
that's mine did you pay for it
and you won't say anything and so i'm
like are you drunk
because you shouldn't be driving and you
won't say anything
so i i said you're not driving because
you're drunk and i start grabbing him
right and i pull him out of his try
pulling on his car and now he starts
like struggling with me and fighting me
and i'm like you [ __ ] you're
getting out of this
[ __ ] car and i'm getting angry yeah
and then he won't get out
so i don't know why i grabbed this foot
i took his shoe
and i threw it across my parking lot i
don't know what
and now you can't draw that's exactly
what i said
i don't know why i knew this would work
cause he's drunk i said that
i said now you can't drive he got out of
his car he's like
well how'd you know that's what made him
get out of his car
and he walked to go get his shoe so he
could
ride with this shoe i don't know so now
he's out of his car
and and all i'm doing now is just
shoving him
out like preventing him from getting in
the car because he's like drunk he's
strong
like you're not going nowhere you can't
drive and you stall
yeah sit down sit down right now yeah
and he's just kind of wrestling with me
so
i'm just shoving him and shoving him
right and he's trying to fight with me
so now he's getting really physical and
grabbing my [ __ ]
so i get physical and i trip him up
with my foot behind him and he falls
over yeah
and as he's trying to get back up i put
him in a rear naked choke
and then i squeeze him pretty hard like
this and so his
my my mouth is right next to his ear and
i'm like
you need to stay down or you're going to
sleep you hear me
you're going to sleep you hear me and
then he goes
okay so i let go and he went
and he passed out he passed out and he
[ __ ] his pants
oh my god he is he is drunk as [ __ ]
[ __ ] his pants so while he's passed out
i run inside
to uh grab the phone to call 911
and when i come out he's up and now he's
finding two elderly people who are
trying to keep him down
two 60 seven-year-old people and they're
trying to like keep him like hey where
you going like
stay down stay out and i come out there
and now i'm on
9-1-1 and then i'm talking with the
dispatch and i'm telling her what's
going on and my address and everything
and i have this guy wrestled down so
yeah i have this guy down a lot of times
smeared all over his ass yeah shit's on
his ass and everything and
um i put my knee on his chest and he's
like
wrestling me because i have him down and
then he [ __ ] grabs my dick
so when i told this story to the jury
right i said
and then the prosecutors like um you
know
asking me what happened because they're
charging him yeah for theft and then
so i'm telling the story and then what
happened
well um then he grabbed my penis and
then someone in the jury
started laughing because the story is so
ridiculous
and the judge gave the jury a stink eye
order she was pissed
but this [ __ ] grabbed my dick
and twisted that [ __ ] yeah
and um you could see it in the video
like
i was really close to him and that was
the moment where like now i can punch
him now i can hit him because before
because he was
assaulting you yeah before i sexually
assaulted him i couldn't just
punch him yeah hit him or anything i had
to keep him down like part of the law is
that
in washington is that a you're allowed
to um keep someone in custody on your
own property
if they're trespassing yeah and so i was
doing that within my legal right but
then when he grabbed my dick was like
when i was like all right now i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up
yeah and he was this close to me so
instinctually i i threw my elbow at him
yeah
and just wham right right over his um
eye and he fell over and when i grabbed
him again
i had actually cut his eye open there
yeah and you know when you see blood
it's like that's it that's the target
yeah and so i hit him again on his eye
and then he started covering up so
when i'm on 9-1-1 with the cops i say
excu
hold on and i put the phone down and i
use my
left hand to grab one of his arms and i
just started grounding and pounding him
yeah
i hit him in the eye and then he covered
his eye like where i already cut him
and has left his nose and mouth open and
yeah i just smashed into it and it felt
like
punching a rotisserie chicken it just
crunched
under there oh wow right and then he
went
stop yeah that was the first time he
said anything yeah because he wouldn't
talk or anything
and so like
all right but i punched him one more
time just
grabbing my [ __ ] dick and right there
like a second later the cop the cops the
sheriff
showed up and they arrested him you know
and then holy [ __ ] like
all this is happening like my hand got
bloodied up from it
and my adrenaline is [ __ ]
raging right yeah and he's just out now
on on the floor and the cops are
arresting him
and these people kept coming in he's
like hey uh can i buy some scratchers
and
oh my god dude it's like hey man i need
a breath
yeah he's like nah i just need i almost
got my [ __ ] penis torn off
no have you been in the position where
your adrenaline
dumps you just oh you're cry i don't
know if i cry but the adrenaline dump i
get
sleepy
yeah yeah i'm like the cops are there
that emt are there
they're arresting him and cleaning him
up because i i broke his orbital bone
cut his eye and his nose was broken yeah
and
these people like all of a sudden we had
a [ __ ] rush of customers
and i'm like trying to check these
people out and i'm like
yeah the adrenaline the bar part of the
adrenaline rush is the worst part and
then i'm like
it's it's three nine like
i get your [ __ ] again i started crying
yeah with the adrenaline dump and
everything and then like
i'm like i'm sorry guys you guys you
guys need to go yeah
and i called my mom to tell her what
happened she was like yeah close the
door just close this door
and i'm not gonna get my cigarettes are
what yeah
they're stop you're crying i just want
some cigarettes but what happened was
those people who saw
they were witnesses they witnessed it
right
that [ __ ] spread like wildfire yeah
this
this town is small yeah so
months later i'm in
i'm in walmart just picking up [ __ ] and
it's late at night it's probably 10 or
11 p.m
and everyone's blue collar there you
know everyone was is wearing dirty car
hearts
you know it's like if you have clean
hearts car uh clean car hearts you're a
poser
yeah okay so trying to be like one of us
yeah
how dare you so super late at walmart
i'm waiting in line there's a guy in
front of me and there's another guy in
front of him
and this guy just turns around just
makes small talk hey how's it going
how's your night
it's like uh you know long day at work
he's like yeah my two
just pulled out 15 hours i'm like hey
man i pulled 15 hours at my store too
he's like really yeah what store i'm
like yeah out there
he goes hey aren't you that guy that
beat up some [ __ ] drunk dude
like i heard him i'm like whoa wait a
second yeah i'm at [ __ ] walmart like
that word spread around yeah what i
found out was this sheriff whenever
people would [ __ ] up
he would show them my instagram and be
like this guy's gonna make you famous
one of the sheriffs was being a [ __ ]
bro that's hilarious and when people
would [ __ ] up
at my store he'd be like see this he's
gonna make you famous
oh my god and that's how people around
town found out
about my instagram like my social media
he's like using you guys as a warning
yeah it's like hey keep your [ __ ]
together this guy will [ __ ] your ass up
yeah i won't do that again it was
traumatizing yeah dude
so like oh my gosh i mean but i i
kept telling you how this [ __ ] never
ends right now yeah
i'm at i i'm at court i'm telling this
story
you know i tell it to the judge and jury
and
um then i'm called out for the defense
to get they don't gotta
they ain't got nothing yeah that's got
nothing because the guy admittedly their
case is that he doesn't remember
anything
and i'm the one who has a testimony like
a very detailed testimony
with video yeah and um he's lost it
you know he lost the case so they call
me back in if i want to say anything
um before they sentence him
and the thing was honestly like
what happened after i i beat him up um
the cops told me like yeah uh we're not
gonna take him to jail we're gonna take
him to the hospital
i'm like oh i didn't and he's like nah
nah like he's saying he wants to kill
himself
he's getting suicidal oh my god right
now i mean look at him he's covered in
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] up
yeah yeah and so i started
feeling like [ __ ] for what i had done
yeah i was like oh my god what did i do
you know and i tried to kept wearing out
what had happened or whatever
so when it came down to it to the
sentencing i'm standing in front of the
judge
prosecutor the defense and i'm like
look um i've gotten in trouble with the
law before too i spent a night in jail
because of my drunkenness
yeah and i was telling and at that time
i had lost a [ __ ] ton of weight and i
totally just i just lost 100 pounds
you know because i quit drinking you
know in my life
i'm trying to get it back together and i
was
like this guy's suffered enough please i
told the judge
like this is at the time i was like i
believe in god
you know and i think the system works
we had a trial and and he should be
sentenced
for what happened but your honor i said
you have the power
you know to show him grace
i think he suffered enough and if you
could show him leniency
i think it would help him have a better
life and then he called you a [ __ ]
that means everybody starts they're like
i don't need your pity well never mind
you just take them away but man that man
the judge started crying
oh really the stenographer started
trying the the person who was
and then the the guy's lawyer started
the defense lawyers started crying and
even though i was getting choked up yeah
and the lawyer was the lawyer who
sentenced my dad
to 14 months in prison holy [ __ ]
and she saw me and recognized me and i
was like i went to jail too because i
had substance problems
yeah and i'm getting my life back
together i lost all this weight and i'm
working up my store and whatever i
didn't know that was the judge who
sentenced my dad to jail
wow and she recognized because i [ __ ]
looked like my yeah you look just like
your dad
yeah i was saying all this and i didn't
realize this and so
she commuted his sentence like the fines
he had to pay
he made it like it could have been tens
of thousands and went down to like
a thousand dollars and he only had to
pay 25 a month
oh wow you know and all his sentences
that he had so if you had to
serve two years oh wow commuted it
and and yeah just suspended you know
what happened to him after
no no his defense lawyer came to me
after
and shook my hand she was like thank you
yeah thank you that [ __ ]
couldn't look me in the eye and just
walk by
and ashamed yeah but at the same time
you know
i felt good like look i've been
in that very same [ __ ] courtroom
where my dad got sentenced
and now i'm in there on the other side
as
in the prosecution side like
i know what it's like yeah sit in the
defense and have nobody
you know therefore like i wonder like
what happened to him like
how did he get to this point yeah i mean
yeah i think the defense lawyer was
saying
like he's from seattle
he lost his all this it's just a spiral
of [ __ ] where he lost his job and that's
why he wanted to die
yeah at the time where he committed the
crime
he was living in a tent at his
ex-girlfriend's in-laws
jesus ex-girlfriend pitting him pitied
him so much that he was
because he was homeless that he lived on
their lawn in a tent
jesus and then this guy was an alcoholic
and decided to steal
beer from me and then i [ __ ] him up
yeah i mean come on man does he have to
spend two years in jail after that
like he needs help he needs a break yeah
and that's what i was asking for and
yeah she gave it to him
and i walked it up out of there feeling
like a million bucks
you know like man something great
happened the [ __ ] one of the sheriff
deputies the the guy who showed up
grabbing big fat handshake like did a
good thing in there
you're a good man prosecutor shook my
hand i told you the defense lawyer
said thank you i went over to fred meyer
in this [ __ ] town to go to their
little pinky ding starbucks
and i went to court so i'm dressed up
right yeah and this lady in line was
like you're not from here are you
i'm like huh because you don't dress
like you're from here and i'm like oh i
feel good because yeah i dress up for
court right
after that i go back home
and um i i go back to my store
i pull up i get on my car i'm walking in
and then i hear [ __ ] it
oh my god and i'm like huh and i turn
around look
and this [ __ ] meth head who gives me
[ __ ] all the time he's [ __ ]
he's got a mohawk with a joker ha ha ha
ha tattoo on his head
just messed up all the time screaming
out of his white
van like with the windows down i look at
him again the second time
he goes [ __ ] oh my
god because i'm dressed up for port and
i'm like
yeah well like i assume that's the way
it's supposed to end out here yeah
like i feel great thank you for that
they're all the things that i want to
give back to this community
this is this is how it is i think this
is why my [ __ ] [ __ ] spiraled out
well see this is the our part too it's
like you don't wanna
you know we always talk about giving
with
out of a gracious heart right this is
the hard part it's like giving without
expecting something to happen in return
you know and keep going keep going so
when these things
happen it's it it you have to try not to
let it chip away
right yeah because it's like that
gracious heart in giving
is is where people i think a lot of
people [ __ ] up with right it's my dad
taught me this
very early on right and he taught me
this by teaching me how to give money to
people
right he goes if you're like for example
like i've had friends who have borrowed
money
borrow money from me right not a problem
and what my dad always said too it's
like
when you give to somebody and you always
expect something
in return you're you're setting yourself
up for failure yeah so if you're in a
position in your life and you could give
money to somebody
that means that that's money that you
can give away and not think about it if
you're giving it away
and you need that money then you
shouldn't have given it away in the
first place
so i think like the the act of doing a
good deed
should be done just in the good deed
itself right and it's hard
because we do feel good when we do great
things
and sometimes when we don't get that
reciprocated back it makes us feel like
we wasted our time
right you know right it's like why the
[ __ ] was
i an altruist when this person is a
piece of [ __ ] back to me
yeah this is what i kind of want to like
ask you like
maybe it's not money right let's talk
about gift giving then
okay because this is where i have a
problem um
when you give someone a gift right
do you give it away out of your
abundance or do you give it
because this person needs something like
this
and they could be a good steward of this
and actually grow
out of um i mean i think it really
depends uh
gifts to me were always odd i actually
don't like giving gifts and i don't like
receiving gifts
because it's not because of this thing
of where i think like oh i don't want
somebody to pity me i'm not that dark
like i don't i don't need that [ __ ]
it's just i always feel i always grew up
in a household where i felt
where my mom made me feel like you
always have more than you need
so why do you keep getting things you
know so
i like giving a gift to somebody is
always hard for me not because i don't
want to give it to them
i just look at somebody and i always
think like you have a lot
dogs you have a bus pass yeah why should
i give you anything
hey life's really key life is good life
is good
it's fantastic so by the way yo
we both love nachos one of my favorite
comedy films of all time and so like
when i when i when i try to give
somebody gifts
i i think obviously i go to the the
typical tropes right it's like
do they already have this yeah would
they like this what would they enjoy
right but when you're an adult and
people are you know your people your
peers are doing relatively well
it's hard to give you know that's why i
like registries
because it's like they're telling us
what they need it's like
cool now i know i won't [ __ ] up boom
can i ask you a personal question yeah
you and i now yeah
this [ __ ] guy gave me his sony
fs700 yeah and i
shot three things in
four years five years
um what do you think uh i i kind of
weighed myself heavy on that like you
gave me this awesome camera
but i never utilized it to its maximum
potential i don't care
because i gave it to you it's not mine
it's yours so what you do with it is up
to you
i i don't like to give somebody
something and hang it over their head is
one of the worst things
an individual can do i [ __ ] hate that
i hate it i hate it i hate it
yeah i mean
because it because it eats it's bad for
you it eats you up inside
once it's gone it's gone right i'm not
talking about two where somebody's like
man dude i can't pay my bills i can't
feed my family and the next day i see
you at a strip club
like that's different that's like you
you lied to me you know what i mean
but when i gave you that camera was
because i'm like
you're out there in the middle of
nowhere you're a filmmaker
here if you want to use it you can use
it if you don't
whatever you know it doesn't matter but
you know even the gesture giving you the
camera it felt good
right it made you feel good yeah we're
done that's
that's what it was for whether you
choose to use it or not is completely up
to you
you know what i mean that's not on me
yeah yeah i mean
i don't want to hold that over your head
i had just had this like guilt
like man i don't know what the [ __ ] to
do with this camera
yeah you could have shot great
landscapes you know what i mean like i
don't know
but at least you had something there in
case you wanted to
yeah well that's a life lesson for me
because i was a dick
about gift giving yeah um
mainly because let's say i felt
justified
in my anger towards it where i gave a
friend my guitar
it's a cheap epiphone you know epiphones
are cheap gibson's made in korea
yeah 300 bucks brand new those things
hurt your fingers like a [ __ ]
yeah
and someone wanted to learn so i gave it
to them and i just wanted them to take
care of it
right that's all i asked really like
because when i gave it to them
i was telling them like um
uh who's the guitarist for
uh aerosmith tyler perry
i can't remember tyler perry well tyler
smith
tyler perry is the black dude
okay you know about my deal you think
perry okay something
guitarist tyler perry did you talk about
medea yeah
sorry something um but
his guitar tech the guy who makes and
sets up his guitars and
is from seattle i went to that guy to
install
actual guest gibson burst parker pro
pickups in it
and set it up for me the guy who [ __ ]
does aerosmith's guitar
and so i gave this guitar to someone
because they want to learn how to play
guitar
and they tore it apart
and wanted to put it back together and i
got offended
like i told you tyler perry's guitar
tech set this up and put this together
yeah and they're like you gave it to me
you know and where i was arguing was
like you're not being a good steward of
this gift
and her their argument was you gave this
to me it's mine
i mean that's a little weird situation
right like
but that's why like i don't give
expecting anything yeah
right once i give it up i mean he's kind
of right it's not yours
right but because you had that emotional
attack i think
you're more angry at the stupidity
because
i'm actually i'm not i'm not upset that
he did that i'm angry at his stupidity
like who the [ __ ] do you think you are i
literally told you who put this together
there's no way that you could take this
apart and do a better job
you're dumb i'd be i'm more upset at how
stupid this person is
you know well that's the thing they're
learning guitar so okay his name is joe
perry
they don't know who joe perry is they
don't really care about aerosmith they
don't know what a guitar tech is or they
don't know what a setup is they don't
know what a pickup is
and so it was like on me it was like
what was i thinking yeah
well i'm saying like that's why when you
give things don't expect [ __ ] from me
yeah
right i learned a very very valuable
lesson
in that about not just gift giving but
like
the value of things or even myself or
what i put the weight i put on and
expectations right dude like even like
the camera gear that i sold i sold for
dirt cheap
yeah right and the people that i sold it
to i know for a fact i'm not gonna use
it
as potential i just know just by looking
at them and i'm like
but they enjoy it yeah you know and it's
like i sold it to for cheap like these
like it was like video bundles like a
starter kit that i would have loved to
have had
right right two thousand dollars a
monitor [ __ ] four batteries for a
seven
a7 r3 right like
monitored like a memory card everything
the whole shebang right
like everything that i needed just to
start minus the lens right it's like
like two grand or like 1900 i'm like
damn i would have killed for this
and then i definitely you know sold this
thing i'm like this
person's probably not going to shoot
with this yeah or they don't know what
to do
yeah but i'm like it doesn't matter like
whatever like i did it out of the
graciousness
like i made nothing off of this you know
i think it was because of my um
past experiences of giving away things
um because as a christian
i told you i sold my [ __ ]
um i gave my some of my stuff away but
one time i actually had
i was really broke and i had to pay rent
and the only thing i really had left was
this taylor
um 414 ce right
now the thing about this taylor was also
that it was a limited
edition maranatha worship leaders
edition guitar
from taylor where it had dove inlays on
the frets all the way to the head
stockhead had this beautiful
dove yeah taylor doesn't make custom
guitars
right this is one of 133 made in the
world holy [ __ ]
right and i was using it to lead worship
like
i got lucky getting my hands on that off
of ebay
and i was leaving church and i was
quitting everything
and i got kicked out of fleeting worship
and all that and there's another
kid that was coming up and um
i saw the potential in him right so i
was like you know what i want to sell
this to him because he's going to keep
learning and he's going to keep doing
this [ __ ]
i can't you know so i sold it to him for
the same
price i bought it for and stuff like
that guitar meant so much because do you
know who doyle dykes is
no so who's that korean kid on youtube
who
plays like guitar things yes i know who
he is
his mentor his guy is doyle dykes he's
his style is doyle dyke style that guy
who okay with this crazy finger picture
yeah
he's also one of the only few people in
the world who has a custom tailor
signature guitar
him and prince they don't do it for and
taylor swift yeah
and they don't do it for anyone so i met
that guy doyle dykes and i showed him my
guitar to sign
right and then he's from the south that
he goes
where did you get this yeah and i'm like
huh
like yeah i bought off ebay he's like
i've
only seen this guitar once and it's
sitting in bob taylor's office
sitting in the wall wow i'm like holy
[ __ ] i was like well you sign it he's
like i can't sign this you want my dirty
hand right now this is like yes
like all right kid i don't know what
you're talking about and he signed it
doyle dykes on the
on the head so this guitar is worth a
lot
yeah i saw this kid and expecting
nothing out of him and you know what
he was a good steward he he fixed up the
pickups when it would break and he's
still leading worship to this day
with that guitar with that guitar and
that was my expectation
with my next guitar yeah it wasn't there
and
i think i faulted in seeing a success
story with uh
yeah well i think because you were also
giving out of
you're expecting an emotional return
yeah
you know so like that's already setting
yourself up for failure you know like
i can't do that to myself i
literally can't do that to myself so
like now it's like
i give and it goes away dude i have a
friend right now like out of all the
money i've given this [ __ ] like
he probably owes me like almost like six
seven grand
you know but this [ __ ] down and
out of his [ __ ] luck yeah you know
what i mean
um so it's like
i'm supporting this dude's dream right
and i've never expected any
anything in return and he's like and you
know this person has tried to pay me
back in other
ways too maybe not with money but with
you know support and time
you know helping me with stuff yeah and
i'll take that [ __ ] it i'll take it yeah
you know what i mean
um but i did have a have to have a
conversation with him about uh
borrowing money yeah because um
though i didn't expect anything in
return i do have a problem with somebody
who borrows money
only because they choose not to work
did you hide like a playstation yeah so
you know
the last time i i lent um
this person money i was like hmm
i was like i'm gonna give you this money
you don't owe me it back
yeah just like i always do however this
time is gonna come with a lecture
you want to take it right he didn't have
a choice he goes i'll take it cool
i was like you're a lazy [ __ ]
all right and he was like you know he's
quiet because he knows it's true he
knows his facts
i was like the difference between other
people and you being down out of your
luck
you don't have money because you don't
want to work i was like
you are a very capable person i was like
think about this right now and this is
all i'm going to say
you rather take money from your friend
than go out there and work hard for it
yourself
how does that make you feel right i was
like
don't ever ask me for money again you'll
take this
it's gone it's out of my head i still
love you we're still good friends
but the only reason why you can't pay
your bills is because
you choose not to work you want to make
money the way you want to make money
right i was like i do things that i
don't want to do all the time but i need
to pay my [ __ ] bills
you don't think like that you want to
live in this fantasy world where you get
to do whatever the [ __ ] you want
and then you rather take money from me
rather than work
was this pre-covered this is pre-coping
because you know this guy could work at
7-eleven
right this is pre-covered yeah so he
could work literally anywhere yeah
like anywhere you know it's like you
choose not to work hours because
you don't feel you don't feel like you
want to that day yeah i was like there's
so many opportunities for you
for you to make money but because it's
not fun you don't want to do it so you
rather take my money
it's the last time you'll ever take
money from me and then it's never asked
since
did he get to work i don't know oh
[ __ ] not my responsibility just i'm not
gonna lend him money yeah so it's like
for him it's like
you know we see we still talk every now
and then and we're still like decent
friends like
like i said i don't hold that against
him at all yeah
but if he asks me for money
i'ma [ __ ] his ass off oh
man for some reason that just reminded
me of this weird story of a guy who
owes money um
so this guy
all right okay we we the i don't know
when the podcast will go we talked about
my sassy girl
yes and a girl who gets drunk and this
guy has to take care of her
i actually want to ask you did you have
to ever have to take care of a drunk
girl who was just
[ __ ] out yes what was that like uh
well
first of all i kind of [ __ ] up so like
um there was this girl so we were in
riverside and there was a concert
in the in the in the middle of the the
quad if you guys do ucr
there's that bell tower and apparently
it was called like a suicide tower so
people would they blocked it off but
people would jump off and kill
themselves
[ __ ] but that's very iconic okay that's
how it got his name
yeah but um this girl
her boyfriend passed away he actually
passed
so this is why i never drink and drive
was because of this story
yeah he actually passed away not because
he was drunk he was walking home
in the middle of night and a drunk
driver [ __ ] crashed into him and
smashed him between the pole
he wasn't drinking god damn and
apparently he was like
reforming his life or whatever what not
you know kind of going on the straight
and narrow because of her
yeah she lost her boyfriend because of
that um that's how my cousin's best
friend died hit and run like that isn't
that crazy
not even his fault yeah so she got
plastered
[ __ ] drunk and so uh
[ __ ] dude like knocked out in the middle
of the [ __ ] quad area i had to pick
her up over my [ __ ] shoulder
and she yacked all over
my [ __ ] shoulder
yeah then we had a [ __ ] firearm
carrier we took her back to uh one of
our friends apartments and this is the
funniest story too
so one of the guys were she's throwing
up
and uh she couldn't make it to the the
bathroom which was only like a few steps
away so we brought this like ceramic
bowl
that they had there so she could throw
up in the bowl and then we would chuck
it out right so she wouldn't get it on
the carpet yeah
already disgusting situation right she
we're holding her hair up one of the
dudes is holding her hair up she's
throwing up
crying and [ __ ] right this [ __ ]
as he's
he's the one in charge of holding her
head up he gets a call from his brother
who hasn't talked to in a while he goes
oh [ __ ] let's go over she smashes her
face into the ceramic bowl
and i'm like bro what the [ __ ] he looks
at me and
as if this is a competent response he
goes dude it's my brother i haven't
talked to him a long time
yo what's up
dude that's how bad it was so
i haven't i haven't told this story to
anyone except
to one person when it happened this
happened in
[ __ ] dude it happened [ __ ] 20 years
ago yeah
so not like
i just graduated so um
um a bunch of friends in tacoma were
having this house party
and they invited this one girl invited
me i was like all right
i'll go with you you know and
um she's a senior in high school i'm a
freshman
so i'm in tacoma at this house party at
her senior graduation party or whatever
and so i show up to this house and guess
who's there
all of the other youth group seniors
yeah all the korean american koreans are
all there
yeah so like all right so i don't feel
weird whatever everyone i go to church
with us here
this girl gets plastered scares [ __ ]
up
you know and so to the point where
she like is just being
wild and her friends
and all those church people that i know
they left they ditched her
and they were like edward let's go let's
leave
how christian is yeah let's dude she's
drunk just leave her
you know i was like nah
nah i'm gonna stick around right and
they're like and roll their eyes at me
kind of thing they thought i wanted to
get drunk and stop acting holy once they
left or something
yeah but this girl was just getting
crazy plastered until
she just kind of passed out upstairs in
this house party
and i went up there to check on her and
then i just hear this
just gargling right i'm like oh [ __ ]
right so
she's in this bedroom so i i'm dragging
her
with dead weight pulling her by her
shoulders and just going like that and i
hear the gurgling coming up
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] so i don't know what i cut
my hands like this
and she's she's in front of me and she's
just
no gag reflex just dribbles all this
barf in my hands and i'm like oh my god
and it's just coming and it's
overflowing in my hands and like
i don't know why i think i can carry
this [ __ ] and there's this house plant
next to me and i just
i just just dump it in there
and then i continue to drag her ass into
the bathroom and just let her [ __ ]
puke right and i'm in the bathroom
and i'm like [ __ ] now i'm in this issue
i'm alone with this girl yeah all these
other people and she's drunk as [ __ ]
and people are banging on the door like
what the [ __ ] is going on in there and
i'm like
[ __ ] this girl's out so i call my hyung
you know i'm like because he lives in
the same neighborhood i'm like
hey hyung um i didn't want to tell him
because i know he's going to beat me up
for being in this situation but i'm like
look i'm with this girl by the paris
party and she's trying out that and he's
like all right just bring her to my
house
right and so i didn't drink all night
actually yeah that night
and i'm trying to drag her ass and
i'm looking for help and there's this
group of guys
in tacoma i'm not gonna say they're not
gonna they're gonna know whatever i call
them they're gonna know who they are
i'm gonna just call him d
um and i'm like yo help me
get her down the stairs because i can't
do this [ __ ] by herself myself she's
dead weight he goes [ __ ] you why'd you
bring her to this party i'm like hey
she brought me here people probably and
he was like
[ __ ] you man why you bring this [ __ ]
girl i'm like holy [ __ ] no one's going
to help me
yeah and
taking her down the stairs by myself and
drag her into
that forerunner i had yeah the same car
yeah i [ __ ] threw in there
and i drove her to my hung's house and
got her cleaned up
right and then her phone started ringing
right my tongue's up we're like for me
i'm like finally [ __ ] safe like
what a [ __ ] weird night and then get
a phone call from this guy it's dee
right he's like hey is this
ed i'm like yo what are you doing what
are you calling they're calling her
phone yeah
what'd you do where's she where'd you
take her we were trying to [ __ ] her
and he literally said it we're trying to
rape her dude
we're trying to rape her and i'm
like oh my god [ __ ] you
we're gonna [ __ ] you up ed we're going
to [ __ ] you up
you know what [ __ ] it d they're called
the chuck e cheese crew that's what we
call them [ __ ] you guys
that's what they said to me [ __ ] them
right and so i disassociated with these
guys he's like korean people at your
church
nah oh they're just like [ __ ] like
coma people scumbags yeah
um the church people left yeah about
this one girl who's a church girl
so by the way [ __ ] drunk as a story
of caution for women
i'm telling you when you go to these
situations
listen be careful right because there
are scummy ass [ __ ] men out there
like legit cause i was just gonna say i
was like she's lucky somebody didn't
[ __ ] rape her dude
and lo and behold these [ __ ] scumbags
are telling me they're gonna kick my ass
for preventing them from raping her
straight up word for work that's [ __ ]
crazy dude
this is what yeah so
i i [ __ ] got heard the safety and all
that [ __ ] and i disassociated with this
guy like i'm gonna call him keep calling
him d
but as i keep hearing about him as we
keep growing up
like this is what happened this is what
i mean about people who owe money
and why i bring it back so full circle
to this
this guy got caught up in the drug game
with one of my hyungs
who everybody knows you shouldn't [ __ ]
with him
this one hyung particularly do not [ __ ]
with him ever
right he's a weird case because when he
was 15
his mom woke him up one saturday and
made him go take the sats
he got a 1590. holy [ __ ] i was out of
1600. he's a smart [ __ ] but he's
a kangpe
yeah he's a kang pencil those are the
scariest people though he's so scary
and but and um he's
he's uh he's in the drug game they push
drugs so this kid d
try to get in it with him
and as it turned out he just
i don't went under in the red and he
owed
my young money and he never had the
money with him and he was like look
the next time i see you if you don't
have my money
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up right so this guy
went
m.i.a for a while and that makes things
worse
yeah and one time at the no at the pc
bang
that that crew was chilling in there
[ __ ]
acura integra this d was in the back
seat and the hyung was just saying hi to
his tongs
he's like hey is that d and he told us
someone's like get out
all you guys you just check it there get
out yeah and this kid's in the back seat
and he [ __ ] him up in the backseat
just [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] out of holy [ __ ] yeah and
from then on whenever he saw him
he'd be like do you have my money and
just [ __ ] him up
right but it came to a point because
this guy never had his money
right that maihong went to his house
where he wasn't hiding because he kept
getting beat up yeah
and he knocked on the door and his
parents opened
he was like hi um you might know me
i have an issue with your son like he
and i have a business
you know kind of quarry like he owes me
money
i think you know about it like yeah it's
like can i talk to him can we talk about
it all right so they're sitting in the
living
room mom dad uh son
d and my hyung
and he told the parents exactly what
happened what they went they had this
deal
with these drugs or whatever and he was
supposed to have this much money and
he doesn't and he said if i ever see him
again i'm going to beat him up if he
doesn't have my money
and his parents are sitting there and he
goes does he have my money
and he does he [ __ ] him up in front of
his parents
oh my he beat the [ __ ] out of them out
of their parents
and here's the thing like i feel like
whoa
we got but i'm also like i remember you
were trying to rape
are you trying to rape a girl yeah this
is the life you chose and his parents
just watched it
that's the thing like i feel like his
parents are like
you deserve it so i
i just know that this story is true
but at going back to it it was just like
paying the money thing pay your debts
and fulfill your expectations
what what happened so what happened to
him did he ever get his money back
no i just know like he's the type of
hyung i would
never be on the wrong side of yeah yeah
ever even one of my closest friends
growing up
like just wanted some credit credit for
providing the space for him to grow his
stock and because
of that he [ __ ] knocked him out oh my
god
so at the same time i'm like you know
what you try to rape a girl
and i took no [ __ ] thought to you and
after the years and i hear what happened
to you i'm like
you deserved it you deserved [ __ ]
karma dude you little piece of [ __ ] he's
the [ __ ]
that's what i'm so it's so crazy too
when i hear like stories like that
that's why i always
i was like i meant i don't want a
daughter it's like dude these guys are
[ __ ] nuts men so like when i hear
stories too where like
these you know some guys too and i've
said this before too it's like you know
a lot of sane men aren't like that but
there's a lot of shitty dudes out there
too there's something wrong
there's something wrong with that where
there's like a group of guys who thinks
it's cool to call themselves chuck e
cheese
you know grown-ass men you know that
think they're really [ __ ] cool
but these were always the people that i
always would have trouble with you know
i mean like i see them but you know like
you know me when i don't like somebody
it's
highly apparent it's very hard to hide
from me you know what i mean
well they don't let's just say they
don't call themselves chuck e cheese
we call them chuck e cheese guys but
like they accepted it but
honestly it's not the type of people you
want to be around yeah it's like you
[ __ ] dweebs it's like
but we used to always say stuff about
people like that too it's like for me
because i i wasn't like ever
gang-related i just happened being
around people who
were very scary individuals my thing was
too it's like if you're not about
that life don't pretend like you are
it's just some serious [ __ ] you're gonna
get caught in the bottom of that
you're gonna be someone's [ __ ] bro i
told the stories on this podcast years
ago or even
not too long i'm pretty sure people
remember the story but
the my very first time i realized like
how different people are was when i
like listen i would go to these like
house parties like i'm invited
not really i'm going with these other
people right these aren't korean guys
these are like [ __ ] like vietnamese
like
thugs and i'm like sitting there and i
remember just feeling like a fish out of
water
you know like i don't belong here but i
wanted to be there
it's almost like you want credit like
you want to you want to be tough or
whatever
you know this is [ __ ] fat the clout
yeah a little korean kid would split
here and [ __ ] coke all the glasses
like you
clearly don't belong here guy you know
when i'm sitting here in this house
party
and there was this dude that and first
of all disgusting house party because he
do spit on the floor and this guy spit
on this dude's air forces
and this dude is a [ __ ] thug yeah
right he gets up and he's like yo
clean my [ __ ] shoe right and the guy
looks at him he goes [ __ ] you
bro i'm talking about he looked at him
stood up and [ __ ] like
i don't know the number i'm gonna make
up an arbitrary number like 10 people
stood up like it was a lot
and they were all strapped and they
[ __ ] flashed their flash their
[ __ ] straps and i'm like
i'm sitting there like p is coming out
like a little p is coming out hey i
forgot mine where's mine
i'm mortified dude yeah i'm like oh my
god
i'm gonna witness a murder tonight i
only came here so i could be cool
you know and i'm trying to be like cool
as [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] you know i'm sitting here and
this dude
punks this dude so bad he gets on his
knees get a napkin and cleans his shoe
off
you know and the guy gets up and he
leaves the [ __ ] house party yeah
you know and i sat there and they just
go back like it's nothing and they're
laughing about it
i'm peeing in my [ __ ] pants you know
what i mean
and i'm just lucky that i'm associated
with those people
i didn't know how serious it was and
that's what i'm saying like if you're
not about that life don't be about that
life
i was on the other end of that oh really
so i was
uh with my friend who used to be my
roommate and he was having this
graduation party
from um he graduated college uw and
i used to live in that apartment so i
came over and he was having this party
and i got plaster drunk so i passed out
like on the floor
and i woke up because this dude [ __ ]
threw a
football right at my dick oh [ __ ] just
who spiraled it right at my dick and i
woke up like
oh what the [ __ ] and all these people
are holding back like
hey what are you doing holding him back
right
and i got up angry like what the [ __ ] is
going on what the [ __ ]
yeah and they're holding him back
constantly right like don't do it
don't do it he's a nice guy yeah don't
don't no no no
like oppa don't like this girl and this
other guy and my friend like don't
know what the [ __ ] like everyone's like
holding him back
um he's a iraqi vet oh [ __ ]
he's have confirmed kills and he was
starting [ __ ] with me
he just want to [ __ ] with me so he can
[ __ ] me up he like ptsd yeah he wanted
to he wanted to rile something so he can
[ __ ] me up yeah and my friend
saved me by holding him back wow
[Laughter]
yeah that's [ __ ] nuts so he has ptsd
for sure yeah yeah he's just trying to
hurt
even in those situations too to just be
like know where the [ __ ] you are
yeah and who you're [ __ ] with yeah
when i look back at that i kind of want
to put that scene in a movie because
i'm in my mind like it's so vivid to me
i can remember what i was telling myself
in my head
i'm like hey don't let these people know
you're a [ __ ]
yeah i mean and i'm trying to sit there
like all cool as [ __ ] in my mind i
guarantee you i looked like i was hard
like
kind of staring him down i guarantee you
i was crying
i guarantee you there's some tears
coming out of my face like oh my god
you know cause what i mean what am i
supposed how old was i like 15. i'm
[ __ ] young dude i don't know about
this [ __ ] you know what i mean i'm like
yo what what
what is this this is crazy you know what
i mean
it was literally watching somebody
belittle another human being like that
because you get caught up in the
let's say masculinity the becoming a man
the coming of
age the the gang is what [ __ ] is the
access to that straight up if you just
do what they say
you know and i think a lot of young kids
get caught up in this yeah and they like
kind of like us because we're so
obedient yeah they don't really care
about us they like us because we just go
we just follow whatever the [ __ ] they
say right you know and then you start to
realize this is dumb
like i'm a [ __ ] but a lot of young
korean kids too think that's the
that's the game yeah and then they they
suck up to you but like yo
you don't have to impress me dude like
yeah yeah sometimes they think that
that's the way it is now but i mean
still it is that way in korea isn't it
like yeah korea i mean for sure like you
know and they pour drinks for them and
also the stuff but in turn obviously
like they treat them really nice or
whatever
i don't care about any of this stuff
just it doesn't work in this society
here yeah they try to enforce that stuff
so
so when i was living in k-town right uh
i was thinking i was
i was in front of um either congee
you know or bb chicken yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah and then um
i'm up i'm out in some parking lot and
some latino dude right comes up to me
he's got a cigarette in his lip
he's like hey bro you got a light i was
like yeah dude
this is when i smoke so i put up my
lighter and i light it for him and hold
him up like this
right and he goes hey what the [ __ ] man
he took this
the light on man so what do you think
i'm gay or something i like my own
cigarette
i was like oh in korean culture that's
what you're supposed to do we do that
too you know it's a sign of respect he's
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] yo i'm not gay
that's so [ __ ] funny dude you know
yeah it's a difference what you were
trying to do something really nice and
how he took it it's like here just take
this
yeah he thought i was like hey you
trying to [ __ ] or something
what the [ __ ] dude yeah what the [ __ ] i
look like football
[ __ ] about this [ __ ] mike [ __ ]
hotel
[ __ ] [ __ ] maricona hotel ass [ __ ]
puto dude what the [ __ ] man you think
i'm trying to [ __ ] suck your bacon
[ __ ] full
[ __ ] man yeah i'm not gonna like try
it i'm terrified but that's hey this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] cheeto should i touch my now
guys what the [ __ ]
dude yeah i mean and so you gotta learn
like where you're at in the situation
you're in
and dude that's [ __ ] such a melting
pot just like cape town such a weird
spot remember that 24 hours in k-town
that place was ghetto dude the the
24-hour fitness yeah
yeah dude that time when we lived i got
punked off my machine
dug so there's this late night spot i
mean
i don't know if i just have bad luck or
i just got this face that people just
want to [ __ ] with
yeah but you know i'm working out late
at night and i'm on the
the lat pull down right and when you go
to a gym too there's certain people that
work out late at night and they're
usually not normal [ __ ] people
you know and i'm there like at 2am yeah
i'm working out
and i go to the lat pulldown machine
this dude yoked this [ __ ]
wife peter long short [ __ ] rag in the
back of his back pocket everything right
i'm sitting here i'm you know i'm going
through that that mental conversation
make sure you don't look like a [ __ ] so
people don't [ __ ] with you right
look like you [ __ ] like you belong
here right yeah and i'm sitting here and
i start doing the lat pull down and this
[ __ ] dude
buff his [ __ ] tatted up wife beater long
shorts rag in the back comes up me goes
hey you're on my [ __ ] machine i look
and i'm like i am on your machine
i just get up i get up and i start doing
[ __ ]
i start going seated rose instead
i never went back to that 24 again that
dude scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
he punked me out of my [ __ ] doing my
lap pull downs
man so i have a similar story um in the
middle of nowhere back in washington
you know for whatever i could do uh with
how shitty it was out there i i lost a
lot of weight and i started working out
so i signed up for a gym out there
and um yeah i lost a ton of weight and
i'm i'm trying to make
going to the gym a regular thing and i'm
trying to actually lift now
so that i can burn fat while gaining
muscle or whatever
and i either was a bench press or some
some machine anything
but this big like like latino dude
like he's he's puffy he's like hey uh
are are you are you done with this
machine can i use it i'm like yeah dude
sure
i'm good you know i mean move on
whatever and
um i go back whenever an hour late
however long my workout is and i'm in i
always
um go in the sauna yeah or
and then take a shower and i get dressed
and i'm i'm in there and getting dressed
this old
80 year old white dude he's like i saw
you
when you were working out and that
and that brown guy i didn't like the way
he was talking to you
i'm like what right like yeah he was
grunting and aggressive and he came up
to you and took your
and i was like are you trying to defend
me from some [ __ ] that i don't even
think
happened because like he asked nicely
yeah
that's what i'm saying about life out
there dude yeah
dude they just have this bias yeah
and like for me it was like i this guy
was
jack yolk and whatever i'm doing doesn't
matter what how hard he's gonna push
yeah i'm gonna walk away this
[ __ ] old white guy was trying to like
come to my like just let me give you a
hug
are you okay yeah did everything are you
okay did he hurt you yeah
like he's actually pretty nice man yeah
he was nice he was like he was like
grunting it
he was i saw how he grunted at you he
pulled an iphone you was like no
yeah he was making [ __ ] up like
he just wanted to see you get your ass
beat yeah like
it'd be so funny too like in the gym
when i'm working out like clearly i'm
like fat and out of shape
and i'm doing a bench you know i put
like a 45 plate on and like a 25 right
and somebody comes up it's like hey man
you're going to use those 245 plates i'm
like what do you think guys
just take it just why do you ask like
you try to make me feel good about
myself you know i'm not going to use
this it's just cordial
yeah like [ __ ] [ __ ] 350 pounds get
this [ __ ] away from me dude
yeah how nice of you thank you you know
[ __ ]
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast
uh you can find ed at ed parkvp
on instagram ed actually is gonna start
or he has started his own
uh podcast bible study at momo yeah it's
a short podcast you get to hear these
fun little stories and you can check it
out bible study at momos go ahead and
give that a listen
and uh genius brains every thursday and
sundays and we'll see you all next time
peace
peace